tear gas in paris an all too familiar
site
france's mayday demonstrations are
traditionally
a show of force by the country's mighty
trade unions
a message for the government that power
lies not with politicians
but with people this year labour unions
were joined by members of the chilejon
or yellow vest movement
that kicked off a wave of
anti-government protests three years ago
the french president emmanuel macron
remains under mounting pressure to
abandon
economic and social reforms as the
country reels from three crippling
coronavirus lockdowns
for some this was about more than
workers rights
but it has a global context we keep on
having protests and then we feel like
protests happen for nothing
no one's listening to us but i think
it's important to keep coming back
in the british capital hundreds gathered
in trafalgar square under the banner
kill the bill against a proposed law
that would give police
extra powers to curb protests feared the
changes will have a chilling effect on
the right to demonstrate
among the crowds black lives matter
supporters and climate change
campaigners distinction rebellion
who paralyzed parts of london in 2019
under the proposed laws people could
face 10 years in prison for defacing
monuments
and large fines for breaching noise
limits
inevitably i think this is a state
repression
this is the government saying that we
don't want you to come out
and voice your concerns against the
system
what these demonstrators are keen to
remind the british government is that
protests by their very nature
are disruptive and that any new laws
designed to curtail people's
right of assembly damage the country's
democracy
in the german capital berlin a peaceful
march by protesters on the eve of mayday
demanding affordable homes
after the constitutional court
overturned a law that set a rent cap on
apartments in the city
85 percent of berliners rent rather than
own their own home
three countries three different
struggles but a common thread
these are the faces of europe's young
students
those struggling to find work others
looking for security in a fragile labor
market
as europe starts to emerge from lockdown
a reminder that many
old frustrations haven't gone away and
in some cases
they've deepened neave barker al jazeera
london